there are some games some games that
call out for you big for you to play
them oh my god
I've looked for this game for years it's
been so hard but I finally tracked it
down the game is called love death
[Music]
oh my god yes
Oh
oh so anyway you start off by talking to
this girl let's just skip the story we
don't we don't need that [__] we're here
for the porn okay great I can finally
move well the graphics are so good
I am so immersed right now look at that
poster where the [__] is everyone oh I
hear I hear something
I hear something oh yes you are Abed
[Music]
yes you are
what the [__] are you oh my god that
laugh wait I can do that better you look
very tired how are you doing oh [__] I
can slap in this game forgot about that
ah okay so this game has the pinch
option if you're into that shame on you
for being a shelf oh my god I'm stunning
her oh [__] oh [__] what the [__] I
pinched the [__] out of her hey girlie
okay I'm sorry don't call the cops
you didn't see anything oh my god what
the [__] what is she doing now let's
find some other girls in this game
I'm sure oh my god what is going on this
game is so him look at that this game is
so empty Oh
having a nap oh my god I'm so sorry I'm
so sorry I didn't mean to do it up she's
back like nothing ever happened
sending a great message to kids are we
Japan all right finally we have a new
girl mrs. pincher let's just pinch her
forehead oh my god what is going on oh
my god what does this keep happening I
[Music]
don't know what that means but it died
1:0 from 100 real quick quick it's like
is it in yet that's horrible
I'm sorry listen I didn't find this game
this game found me okay we got another
girl and random and with a lot of hair
on his face and now random man with a
lot of hair on his face is leaving and
so is she
best gaming Oh what it [__] did she oh
my god how did this happen No
abort abort mission no no mutt mutts yep
oh my god nudity okay alright I'm just
oh my god she likes it I don't okay how
did this keep happening
Skippy's [__] up Oh
or dad it's not a lollipop finally some
action
all right you can't just stare at it for
too long it's gonna get scared all right
I'm just gonna beat the [__] out of
everyone now [__] this game oh I'm gonna
surf you now that's right [__] you're
my surfboard best game yes we're gonna
go to Disneyland I'm in space
all right press this has been a pleasure
to serve with you today if you enjoyed
watching please leave a like and I'll
see you press on the other side
[Music]